I I I think it's like end of the  Republic like  nastiness that comes out when the  society is so you know so wealthy and so  opulent that it doesn't know what else  to do but what in investigating it what  have you seen as like Solutions or  countermeasures too I don't know teach  children other things maybe more moral  or that align more with your morals well  number one is don't send our kids to  public school so yeah that's that's all  I can say  um I think that that will help a lot and  I know it's really difficult a lot of  people it's their only option I'm really  fortunate I never I I went to private  school and I feel really grateful  um but I think that I think the root  cause of a lot of the problems we're  seeing now is public schools